TO DO MORE TO SECURE CRITICAL
MEDICAL SUPPLIES THEY NEED.
>> Ed: THE CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR
NEWSOME ANNOUNCING A STATEWIDE
STAY AT HOME ORDER FOR 40
MILLION PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE.
>> A SOCIAL CONTRACT HERE.
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO DO
MORE AND TO MEET THIS MOMENT.
PEOPLE WILL SELF-REGULATE THEIR
BEHAVIOR, WE WILL HAVE SOCIAL
PRESSURE AND THAT WILL ENCOURAGE
TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
A LOOK SAYING RECONSIDER BEING
OUT THERE ON THE BEACH OR 22
STRONG AT A PARK.
>> Sandra: LET’S BRING IN OUR
PANEL.
DR. ALVAREZ AND DR. OZ JOINING
US.
WE APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING.
DR. OZ, WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO SAY TO
EVERYONE STAY AT HOME?
>> I WAS DOING NEWS LAST NIGHT
WITH LOS ANGELES FOX AND THEY
SAID WE EXPECTED THIS BECAUSE WE
ARE ALREADY DOING IT.
THERE WAS NOT A LOT OF OUTCRY.
PEOPLE SAID THANK GOODNESS THAT
NEWSOME DEMONSTRATED LEADERSHIP.
HE TOOK THE FOLKS ON THE BUBBLE
AND FORCED WHAT EVERYONE WANTED
TO HAPPEN.
MY SON OLIVER IS A JUNIOR.
THE SCHOOL CEASED OPERATIONS FOR
THE REST OF THE YEAR BECAUSE OF
COVID-19.
TO SAY MY GENERATION HAS TO OWN
UP.
THIS IS OUR OMIT TO BE THE
GREATEST FERNINGS.
-- GENERATION.
THE YOUNG PEOPLE DON’T
UNDERSTAND THEY ARE A HUGE
PROBLEM BECAUSE THEY DON’T KNOW
THEY ARE SICK.
THEIR SYMPTOMS ARE TRIVIAL BUT
THEY ARE VECTORS FOR INFECTION.
PEOPLE WHO ARE PRE-SYMPTOMATIC
ARE A REAL ISSUE.
THE DURATION OF QUARANTINE
SHOULD BE 3 WEEKS.
IN CHINA PEOPLE WERE SHEDDING
VIRUS FOR WEEKS AFTER THEY WERE
ILL.
>> Sandra: THEY MIGHT EXTEND
THAT WHEN THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
BRIEFING AN HOUR FROM NOW.
DOCTOR STHAT NECESSARY IN OTHER
STATES?
>> I THINK SO.
I THINK SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
EVERYTHING DR. OZ SAID NOT
MAKING THE YOUNG PEOPLE VECTORS
FOR COMMUNITIES.
SOME OF THE DEATH RATES THEY ARE
AFFECTING OLDER POPULATIONS.
PEOPLE OVER 65 AND WITH
UNDERLYING MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
IF YOU ELIMINATE THE VECTOR OF
YOUNG  PEOPLE NOT PAYING
ATTENTION.
I GIVE THEM CREDIT.
I THINK THEY ARE GETTING THE
MESSAGE.
BUT WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO THAT
PRESSURE.
>> Ed: DR. BURKES WAS ON WITH
BRET BAIER LAST NIGHT ON
"SPECIAL REPORT" AND TALKED
ABOUT KEEPING THE PRESSURE ON
AND HOW THE FUTURE IS IN OUR
HANDS.
LISTEN.
>> WE KNOW WHAT TO DO NOW TO
STOP THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS.
ARE WE AS AN AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
A COMMUNITY OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
CARE FOR EACH OTHER WILLING TO
MAKE THIS PERSONAL SACRIFICE TO
CHANGE THE COURSE OF THE VIRUS?
SO IT’S NOT 25 MILLION OR 5
MILLION INFECTED BUT MAYBE
50,000 TO 150,000 INFECTED.
THAT’S THE POSSIBILITY THAT WE
HOLD IN OUR HANDS.
>> Ed: DR. OZ WE ARE SEVERAL
DAYS INTO THE 15 DAY GUIDELINES
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
I KNOW WE CAN’T GO THROUGH EVERY
SINGLE COMMUNITY.
BIG PICTURE HOW ARE WE DOING IN
TERMS OF PROGRESS?
>> CITIES LIKE NEW YORK WHICH
REPRESENT ONE-THIRD OF THE ALL
OF THE VIRUS ARE SUFFERING.
I THINK WE ARE SEEING THAT
EARLIER ACTION BEFORE YOU HAVE
THE LOSS OF THE VIRUS AND YOU
CAN’T CONTAIN IT ANYMORE WORKS.
WE ARE CRACKING DOWN HARD HERE
IN NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA.
THE MOST IMPRESSIVE BIT OF NEWS
ON THIS ENTIRE PANDEMIC FRONT
THE PAPER FROM FRANCE YESTERDAY.
WE ARE ALL STUNNED.
IT’S 2 OLD DRUGS.
A MALARIA DRUG AND A Z-PACK.
IT CAN REDUCE THE VIRAL LOAD ON
PEOPLE WITHIN 3 DAYS AND ALL OF
THE VIRUS IS GONE IN 6 DAYS.
IF THAT’S TRUE, THAT
DRAMATICALLY CHANGES EVERYTHING.
WE CAN SUFFOCATE THIS VIRUS MORE
RAPIDLY.
IT WILL BEHAVE MORE LIKE
SEASONAL FLU.
>> Ed: DR. MANNY, ARE YOU
OPTIMISTIC AS WELL?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE PROGRAMS INSTITUTED, I AM
BULLISH ON THIS PROTOCOL.
IT HAS SHOWN IN EARLY RESULTS IT
DECREASES THE VIRAL LOAD.
IT’S A DRUG THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF EXPERIENCE WITH.
I THINK IF WE CONTINUE AND SHOW
PROMISE THIS IS A PATHWAY TO
TREATMENT OR PREVENTION IT WILL
MAKE THAT WINDOW SHORTER.
>> Sandra: DR. OZ, THE WHITE
HOUSE 15 DAY GUIDELINES.
THEY CONTINUE TO ALTER AND
CHANGE THEIR GUIDELINES.
WE HAVE SEEN THEM EVOLVE OVER
TIME.
THE GATHERINGS OF OR 10 PEOPLE.
HOME SCHOOLING.
AVOID TRAVEL AND EATING AND
DRINKING AT BARS AND
RESTAURANTS.
QUARANTINE ENTIRE HOUSEHOLD IS
ONE MEMBER IS DIAGNOSED.
FOCUS ON PROTECTING THE
VULNERABLE.
OBVIOUSLY THAT MESSAGE CONTINUES
AS WELL.
FOR SO MANY, DR. OZ, I AM SURE
YOU WALK DOWN THE STREET AND GET
PHONE CALLS, PEOPLE CAN DRIVE
THEMSELVES NUTS TO KEEP THEIR
HOUSE CLEAN OR PREVENT THEIR
KIDS FROM GOING OUT TO PLAY.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO STAY
SANE AND ALSO PROTECT OUR
FAMILY?
>> OVER THE LAST 24 HOURS, I SEE
A MASSIVE TRANSITION FROM A
PERIOD WHERE DOCTORS WERE YELL
ASKING SCREAMING WITH NURSES AND
SAY PAY ATTENTION.
NOW, I THINK WE ARE FEELING MORE
OPTIMISTIC.
I AM SEEING MORE FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES HEARING FROM VIEWERS
THAT ARE MORE PANICKED THAN WHAT
IS APPROPRIATE BASED ON WHAT I
KNOW.
IF WE ARE GETTING OPTIMISTIMMIC
AS DOCTORS YOU SHOULD FEEL
BETTER AS WELL.
WE ARE SEEING SOME BENEFITS FROM
THE INVESTOR COMMUNITY.
THEY DIDN’T SINK THE STOCK
MARKET YESTERDAY.
I FEEL MORE BULLISH THAN I HAVE
IN A LONG TIME IN PART BECAUSE
OF NEW DATA AND THE GOVERNMENT
HAS DONE WHAT WE KNEW WOULD
WORK.
IT WILL TAKE TIME.
WHEN YOU ARE GOING TO CAUSE
PAIN, YOU CAN DO IT FAST OR SLOW
LIKE RIPPING OFF A BAND-AID.
NOW THE BAND-AID IS ON.
MANAGE THE EMOTIONAL ISSUES.
>> Sandra: DO YOU SHARE THAT
OPTIMISM?
>> I DO.
FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS I WANTED TO
BE OPTIMISTIC.
SOMETIMES WE BECOME OPTIMISTIC
AND ARE CRITICIZED BY OTHERS.
WE ARE TAKING THIS SERIOUS.
WE WANT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND THE RESEARCH AND WE WANT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO BE
PREPARED FOR ANY ISSUES AND WE
WANT THE GOVERNOR’S IN THE
STATES TO FOLLOW-THROUGH.
I AM GETTING OPTIMISTIC.
THE SHORTAGES OF THINGS THAT
PEOPLE ARE PREDICTING, IT WON’T
BE REAL IN THE SHORT TERM.
I THINK THESE CLINICAL PROTOCOLS
WILL MAKE CHARGERS WHICH ARE
POSITIVE.
I LOOK AT THE RESEARCH FROM
BIO-TECH COMPANIES.
THE PLASMA THERAPY OR
MEDICATIONS.
THERE IS A LOT OF GOOD WORK
COMING OUT OF IT.
I THINK WE WILL BEAT THIS.
>> Ed: UNDER A MINUTE.
LIGHTNING ROUND.
DR. OZ FIRST A WEEK AGO.
TALKING ABOUT THE BALANCE OF
TAKING IT SERIOUSLY BUT NOT
PANICKING.
PEOPLE PREDICTED THAT HOSPITALS
WILL FACE DIRE CONSEQUENCES.
DO YOU THINK WE ARE STARTING TO
TURN THE CORNER AND FLATTEN THAT
CURVE THAT DR. FAUCI TALKED
ABOUT?
>> IT’S IMPOSSIBLE TO TELL.
I DON’T KNOW ABOUT SUPPLIES.
MY HOSPITAL IN NEW YORK IS
GETTING SQUEEZED.
AND THE BLOOD BANKS ARE SAYING
PEOPLE STILL HAVE TO DONATE
BLOOD FOR EMERGENCY CASES.
BLOOD PRODUCTS DON’T LAST THAT
LONG.
THERE ARE STILL THINGS WE NEED
TO MANAGE IN THE SUPPLY CHANGE.
WE WILL SUFFOCATE THIS PANDEMIC
VIRUS.
IT WON’T TAKE US MORE THAN THE 4
WEEKS MOST PEOPLE EXPECT.
>> Ed: LAST WORD?
>> I ECHO WHO DR. OZ SAID.
KEEP THE SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FOCUS ON PEOPLE STAYING HOME.
CHILDREN AND PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
DISABILITIES.
THAT CONCERNS ME A LOT.
THAT CAN BE A PROBLEM.
WE HAVE TO MULTI-TASK IN THIS
TIME OF NEED.
>> Ed: STAY INSIDE.
TWO OF THE BEST DOCTORS RIGHT